Hello Freak bitches and Kuhn.
No,
Cabo warm,
warm.
There's me
chewing up.
Oh God.
Damn storm,
man.
This is when fear factor was awesome,
If I met this dude right now,
today,
if I saw that dude today,
I'd be like,
nice to meet you.
Like I never,
I don't remember medium.
That's so great.
My memories such dog shit.
Wow.
My memory's pretty good for like normal stuff,
but I think I've seen too much all these people.
I don't know who these people are.
This is where obviously met them.
That dude,
it's going at town though.
Look at them.
This is when fear factor was amazing.
Not Ludicrous,
man.
Call me.
I'll give you some tips.
When did we talk about this?
Like one of those stunts is like,
oh no,
you're going to get your cell phone wet.
I'm like,
no,
no.
They're on a budget.
Yeah.
Luda might've ate up that budget
fast and the furious gig money.
Now he's stuck in that world with the Tyrese and all those guys on their
franchise.
Did we talk about ty Reese and the rock?
Oh my God.
Did we talk about it yesterday?
We mentioned it off.
We didn't talk about,
I have no idea.
I was,
I was a on youtube looking at something else.
I was looking at,
uh,
some automobile thing and uh,
I saw the rock and then I saw the rock distant Tyrese and I was like,
this is real.
And I went to it.
No,
it's real.
They apparently,
Tyrese talked a bunch of shit about the Rock and the rock did a review of
Tyrese,
his album,
but they're also in a movie right now together.
It doesn't matter.
He doesn't like them.
Yeah.
The things coming out because the rock made a deal to make a,
a spinoff sequel to the fast and the furious franchise that's not bring
involving anyone that's in the Fresno area and they're mad.
Tyrese is like,
you're splitting up the family,
which means nobody wants to go see a Goddamn Tyrese movie.
That's the real problem.
Yeah.
I'm on team rock whenever he wants.
I love the rock.
You too.
He's a sweetheart of a guy.
If you meet him in person too.
Oh,
you got to meet him.
Yeah,
he's great.
At Tate did if movie with him Jumanji he's a fucking great guy.
Like a legitimately great guy and he inspires the shit out of me.
You know,
a lot of people think that that meat heads stuff like in the gym,
like push harder,
get it done.
You know,
all work,
all play all day.
You know,
like all that.
Krista,
I find him inspirational.
I don't care if it's,
I don't care if it's simpleton stuff.
I think he's great.
I love him.
It was pretty good.
Yeah,
we got gimme some volume ma'am.
I just wrapped a phenomenal workout here and the Iron Paradise got after it.
Hardcore,
hardest workers in the room.
It's how we do it.
Um,
the number one question that I'm asked everywhere I go around the world is
always,
how is it that I stay so motivated?
What are the motivating factors in my life that keep me in this psychological
space?
Um,
number one will be gratitude.
I try and find a way to be grateful for every single I have,
every single day.
Wins,
losses,
loved ones,
you name it.
My life wasn't always this way.
It was much different many moons ago.
So these days I'm grateful to the bone for everything.
The other thing is hunger.
Uh,
you always hear people say,
well,
it's about being number one about being at the top or how about this?
You always got to find somebody out there who's going to work harder.
Well,
I don't know that that might be bullshit,
but I know no one is going to be hungrier than I am.
Uh,
and I try and find a way to be grateful.
So I hope that helps.
It's two o'clock in the morning.
If you're watching this,
you better be doing something productive and not freaky shit.
While you could go do some freaky shit Saturday night.
Need a little editing.
Yeah,
but I liked the point.
Get inspirational that all that saying about gratitude,
that's real.
It's legit.
And who fucking works harder than that guy?
He's always on a new TV show.
He's got 10 movies.
Juggling at the same time.
Probably sleeps two hours a night.
Look at him.
I could do without all these pictures of people hopping in private jets though.
I get it.
I hear rich is that the private jet thing to me is,
is just,
that's a weird form of Selfie.
You know,
like the private gym photos I get,
but the private jet photos,
here's the guy that,
that fake the private jet.
Oh Wow.
Bao.
Wow.
That's amazing.
Now,
isn't it?
Yeah.
Like people pretending to little bow things.
And what's funny is nowadays flooding that someone on the plane busted him.
Okay.
[inaudible].